candidate Donald Trump promised that
he'd be a cheerleader for America and we
will make America great again he built
his career as a marketer and as
president he's shown that marketing
boxing
in England he found a way to mention his
Scottish golf course in an interview you
look at the ocean and the waves crashing
on the rocks and the magnificence of it
in a press conference well if you
remember I was opening Turnberry the day
before brexit and on Twitter
he also stayed there it's great to be
with you but in Helsinki Donald Trump
the marketer of America didn't show
presidents often use international
moments to wear the sandwich board of
America Ronald Reagan in 1987
on the table will be not only arms
reduction but also human rights issues
about which the American people and
their government are deeply committed
when liberty and freedom are threatened
American presidents show solidarity
John Kennedy in 1963 as a free man I
take pride in the words ich bin ein by
alina in helsinki the world was watching
the trump administration says that
russians are actively trying to
undermine democracies and the most
powerful democracy america is nothing
special but simply self-interested in
grubby like all the rest you said that
the president's comments were bizarre
and flat-out wrong senator Ben Sasse
took a crack at what a cheerleading
rebuttal might sound like we believe
that seven and a half billion people
across the globe are created with
dignity that they have the rights to
free speech and assembly and press and
religion and protest president Trump
instead said both countries were to
blame for bad relations I think we've
all been foolish asked to broker a
dispute between American intelligence
and Vladimir Putin he said he had
confidence in both President Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today days before the President
had confronted NATO leaders in public I
let them know that I was extremely
unhappy but in Helsinki wanted no
confrontation with Russia over actions
past or present or even the mild
abrasions that might come from
cheerleading freedom and liberty